welcome to this video yes this is a new
video and it's 1d for ya the opening
challenge week is completed so I'm going
to play a little bit of my standard
openings more in the next couple of days
in fact this first opening week opening
challenge week was very enjoyable i will
do that more but i feel like it's a good
idea to have it a bit differently yeah i
just started like in the middle of the
week and I'd like to have it really from
monday to sunday so i'm going to play
some more standard openings for me now
for a couple of days and then I'm going
to start something new um in the coming
monday so something like an opening
challenge maybe with a predefined set of
openings and i'm going to review them
later yeah like starting on a Monday do
the final batch on the sunday after that
and then also do a review on that so I
think this is probably an interesting
idea something that was suggested in
them discussion about about the whole
thing and something that I like very
much it also helps me to to get more out
of the games let's aim to to review them
afterwards I sometimes do that on my own
but it's very often it's a matter of
disciplinary do you do really do it Jim
and if I have this kind of review video
I am I will okay so this is a classical
Kings Indian the so-called mar del plata
variation um black is shooting for Jafar
g4 I'm going for play on the King side
this isn't on the queenside I'm sorry
and on the C file this is an opening
line that i discarded a long time ago
from a place simply because i got
checkmated too often yeah the play on
the Queen's item is nice but black is
quite often just attacking your king
and yeah I had problems problems with
this type of position um so but I'm
going to play a little bit more simply
because I want to yeah very the openings
and try out things that I have not
played for a while and not so
experienced in um I wonder night be five
if we can just go a six it's quincy to a
move or the different queen move there
also may be 84 maybe let's go away for
i'm really not very familiar with this i
played this type of position when I was
like yeah junior player because back
then they really didn't have much much
else ya then then the classical Kings
Indian like that with 91 there was no
bionet attack or whatever so what about
this 9 p-5 is going to go a six I wonder
if Quincy to as I move on is this
ridiculous I ridiculous it probably
isn't it will go Bishop d7 i can go
queen bee three here yeah maybe the
Queen on the third-ranked might be
useful for defense after a possible g4
so rock g7 this is what they normally do
okay still not be five is not not
leading to much a 690 but maybe still a
six nights if night a three night c4
Knight b6 and I have a possible books
III which is often a good way of them
often depending on the third-ranked I
always get nervous if they have this g4
so um it's it's really an opening that
far outside of my comfort zone but let's
see how it works out
at least he is some spending time I mean
miss moves were mostly very standard for
this type of line so he could have
played that probably much quicker j6
looks very normal now I think I wonder
if night c7 doesn't move actually like
rook c7 Bishop f5 but probably just 97
is enough after a six I go to a three
this move was really not threatening
that much yeah maybe just g4 or night
age from so he decides to to really go
for that you know I had already decided
that 97 is not going to work yeah yeah
definitely g4s is coming so um it's nice
you for even possible on is this no good
at all one night see 4g for ya take a
couple of times it is it is dangerous
I take a couple of times the 10 20 kanji
form and you do is directly under attack
that's very dangerous already but if
they're probably quindi one looks like a
very passive move
hmm I don't really see how to how to
defend this properly g4 is going to be
very dangerous this is already accepting
a possible loss of an exchange so
if he takes a couple of times there at
the end this rook takes g4g to Hanks I
was planning rook f2 so on then on f3 I
can play root gap three yep so we take
here not sure even even night takes g2s
a very much a movie em but ok let's take
an IG two comes into consideration quite
a bit which is not saying that this is
bad it's just that maybe nine txt to was
even stronger ok I think after f3 rook
takes f3 this might not be totally
totally clear ok so it's just a texture
to show certainly possible take be son
is going to go which it to time morning
yeah yeah not much you can do him so
attacking eform and taking g3
it's just lost her what can you do yeah
as I said this is a very dangerous
opening and I if you don't know it will
be dangerous just lost him he didn't
really need to do much just play the the
various standard moose yeah some in that
current moves by white were totally
enough to to lose the game
yeah Knight f3 is going to come check
somehow I'm still not I'm sure run
probably lost but it's still still it
continued somehow check check check
check check check check I've got to Drew
here actually but you're spinning
entendre uh-huh check what yes this is a
complete draw at the end yeah but he was
completely winning so yeah that was
probably a very bad way to play this I
think probably around here this is still
about about theorem should be should be
known somehow this kind of thing but
probably I'm doing something wrong
around here I think they play for quick
wins two nite be five but really I
wasn't familiar at all maybe queen bee
three is already bad it's very difficult
to see how to how to prevent g4 after
that night h24 it's going to be very
dangerous may I could have done that the
comp gives the smooth I saw the idea but
I thought he can do this I can simply
take here and play quindi six prolly no
that's not the point rook takes a
stronger I am ok yeah yeah that's much
stronger but that's probably probably
winning for white actually I'm going to
take that now I g4 is not going to
happen
hmm and that was the was a key point
yeah yeah i'm already in huge trouble I
cannot prevent g4 anymore well the
engine is giving you create that's a
strong medicine probably not a bad idea
to be honest in comparison to the game
at least g4s not going to hit and I have
ideas like not to be six I can still go
jihad yeah there's this idea in here
night h5 it's very dangerous I know why
I usually don't play this line I just
wanted to give it a give it a try but
round here it's just it's just awful and
it's very easy to play I mean he didn't
have to do anything special here to get
a winning position ok it screwed it up
later but it was totally totally lost
even hear the end games lost the chance
that bites and blundered blundered all
the powers back so it was a draw but ok
it's 50 so not much that she can do yeah
the advice to take from that is that
this kind of line should only be played
if you really know it well which I don't
and even I mean you took a long time so
maybe he wasn't the greatest expert day
as well but he completely killed me so
only go for that if you know what you're
doing not not like me ok well thanks for
watching